ce samedi l'afghanistan a une fois de
plus était secoué par une attaque
meurtrière entre 8 heures et 10 heures
du matin trois bombes à retardement ont
été déclenchées dans le centre de kaboul
l'attak qui ciblait des véhicules
militaires a fait cinq morts dont un
civil alors que deux autres ont été
grièvement blessés un drame qui
intervient à quelques jours de l'annoncé
du président américain joe biden de la
poursuite ou non du retrait de troupes
américaines lancé par son prédécesseur
donald trump et du côté de berlin quand
on semble clairement pencher pour un
séjour prolongé à kaboul
je suis très reconnaissante envers
l'administration américaine et sa
décision de réévaluer le processus de
paix en afghanistan
l'allemagne est prête à rester plus
longtemps en afghanistan si cela permet
de mener à bien notre mission et si cela
nous permet de vraiment donner une
chance aux forces démocrates éprises de
paix en afghanistan washington accusent
les talibans de ne pas avoir mis un
terme aux violences et de ne pas avoir
coupé les liens avec al qaïda
contrairement à l'accord conclu en
février 2001 à doha j'ai dit à nos
alliés que quelle que soit l'issue de
notre examen états unis n'entreprendront
pas un retrait précipité ou désordonné
de l'afghanistan qui mettraient en
danger leur force ou la réputation de
l'alliance à l'heure actuelle aucune
décision n'a été prise quant à notre
futur dispositif de forces le retrait
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan
présente dans le pays depuis 2001
inquiète une partie de la population qui
voit dans ce départ un moyen pour les
talibans de renforcer leur mainmise les
attentats des derniers mois n'ont pour
la plupart pas été revendiqué pourtant
les talibans sont clairement montré du
doigt la violence n'est pas dirigé
contre nous ni contre nos amis de l'otan
au sein de la coalition elle est dirigée
contre l'armée et les services de
sécurité afghans et contre la population
elle vient principalement des talibans
si les pourparlers entamés en septembre
dernier n'ont pour le moment pas abouti
la russie a pris vendredi l'initiative
d'envoyer en afghanistan
le diplomate asnières kouba love pour
rencontrer des hauts responsables
pakistanais et des talibans
au programme pour l'envoyé du kremlin la
poursuite d'un processus de paix qui
pourrait un jour permettre au pays d'en
finir avec deux décennies de conflit